[Music]
when you get an external impression of
some pleasure guard yourself as with
impressions in general against being
carried away by it
nay let the matter wait upon your
leisure and give yourself a little delay
next think of the two periods of time
first that in which you will enjoy your
pleasure and second that in which after
the enjoyment is over you will later
repent and revile your own self and set
over against these two periods of time
how much joy and self-satisfaction you
will get if you refrain
however if you feel that a suitable
occasion has arisen to do the deed be
careful not to allow its enticement and
sweetness and attractiveness to overcome
you but set over against all this the
thought how much better is the
consciousness of having won a victory
over it
in chapter 34 epictetus is providing us
with some useful advice
that has to do with a certain kind of
appearance something that's coming to us
from the outside and it's the appearance
as he says of a pleasure
and things that we find pleasant or at
least we believe to be pleasant because
they're presenting themselves to us in
that way they may actually be pleasant
those things awaken and orient our
desire our aurexis now remember back to
chapter 2
where epictetus said the promise of
desire is that you will get what it is
that you want that is what appears good
to you and pleasure seems to be a mode
of goodness so this is something that we
encounter every day
and we if we're going to live a stoic
life we have to really be on guard
against it that doesn't mean that we
rule out every pleasure
per se
but we need to think through what what's
being presented to us and so
epictetus gives us some some useful
pointers here he says when you get an
external impression of some pleasure
right something is coming to you and
saying hey this would be pleasant that
that's gonna taste great uh wouldn't it
be nice to indulge yourself and and you
know sitting in the sun and just
relaxing and not doing any work hey why
don't you go over there and uh have a
cigar you know in my case right sit down
and have a cigar and maybe a coffee and
just just enjoy yourself so he says
guard yourself
take care of yourself
as with impressions in general so this
is a general idea
against being carried away by it when we
allow ourselves
to just
respond to stimuli
that we're not even really sure about
we in effect reduce ourselves beyond the
level of the the human we we're not
taking advantage of the fact that we not
only have a faculty of choice that's
free that at least in respect of things
that really fall within its purview but
that we're capable of governing
ourselves because we're able to reflect
on things and we're able to say yes and
no
in ways that other animals can't
so he goes on and he says instead let
the matter wait on your leisure
give yourself a little delay
now
think about it if we personify the
external things that confront us and say
hey wouldn't you like to
you know engage with me there's a cake
over there wouldn't you like to eat me
there's you know an opportunity over
there wouldn't you like to to enjoy me
these things are
trying to make us hurry up and it's sort
of like the ultimate con game you know
con artists don't want you to think too
long about what's going on they want you
to make a decision right away because if
you you know if you think about it and
you reflect on it you start analyzing
things you'll be like wait a second
what about this that you're saying here
this doesn't actually hold up and it's
the same thing with pleasures
they they want us to act on them right
away or at least they present themselves
in that that sort of way i'm
personifying them instead it's really us
we have a tendency within ourselves to
feel rushed oh i better take advantage
of this right now and of course we live
in a culture that long ago learned that
lesson and uses that as a sales pitch to
us for so many things you've probably
heard of foma which is fear of missing
out
that's something that gets played on
quite a lot and sometimes people don't
even need to have outside things you
know impinging on them that way they've
already got it so ingrained in their
character that they're constantly on the
lookout so just take a little pause
take a little break
this is always good advice
if you want to be prudent
you want to proceed in a deliberate
manner
so he says okay you've given a little
pause now think
what should you think about think about
two periods of time
first that in which you will enjoy your
pleasure and second that in which after
the enjoyment of it is over you will
later repent and revile your own self
and the word here for repent is actually
the verb mata noe says you will have a
change of mind it's it's the same word
by the way that's used for repentance in
religious literature coming from about
the same time as epictetus
so if you consider these two time
periods
the time period in which you will be
enjoying the pleasure and we'll use a
couple examples to illustrate this and
the time period afterwards where you'll
be like oh that really wasn't worth it
what was i thinking then
that will help put this in perspective
so let's think for example
about
something that many people are are
confronted with um cheating in in a
monogamous monogamous relationship right
uh almost said mahogany there for a
second so a monogamous relationship
you're supposed to uh be faithful to
each other and that's a very important
value for stoics uh it has to do with
justice
and let's say that you actually do have
the opportunity to cheat uh you have a
one-night stand or something like that
if you do that
hopefully it'll be quite pleasurable
because that's the only reason to do it
and it's not even a good reason but
that's the only real reason to do it i
suppose you could say otherwise you want
to stick it to your your you know spouse
or partner and make them you know
jealous or those are terrible reasons
right
so how much pleasure are you going to
get
it's probably not that much when you
compare it to
a much longer period in which you're
going to feel bad about it in which you
have to worry about what if this other
person finds out in which you have to
think about the fact that you threw away
fidelity a you know a very high value
you damaged your person and you probably
damaged your relationship with the
person who presumably you care about
more
let's use another example eating right
you go to the buffet this is an example
i use quite a lot you go to all you can
eat buffet and you have your first
course right now you say well you know
i'm still not quite full i'm going to go
have a second course and there's a lot
of nice things out there on the on the
buffet and you've eaten enough you can
actually feel that you've eaten enough
but you look out there and there are the
appearances right of tasty things things
that will give you pleasure and you're
like you know a third wouldn't really
hurt me i don't do this that often
let's go do it and so you load your
plate up and you come back and you you
know you eat your food
okay so there's a certain pleasure there
usually followed by
some pain
perhaps some repentance particularly
if you're trying to stay you know trim
or if you're actually trying to lose
weight or anything like that
it's not healthy to eat like that and so
you know you balance these out if you do
that it'll help you to make the decision
no no the pleasure it is pleasure but
it's not really worth it compared to
what i have to encounter afterwards
so he goes on and he says there's
another consideration too
against these two other periods of time
set how much joy and self-satisfaction
you will get if you refrain and again
these are actually verbs here um hydra
says to to to rejoice
how much you will rejoice and
says
means how much you will praise yourself
it's not just that you'll feel
self-satisfaction it's that you'll say
things to yourself like hey buddy you
did it you stood up against pleasure and
that's a tough thing to do you're
actually making some progress instead of
having negative self-talk you'll have
positive self-talk now if you balance
that if you balance the first two out
and then you throw in this this third
consideration that really tips the scale
and that should help you and the more
that you do it the more you make a
practice of this the more it's going to
help you but notice what you have to do
first you have to take a pause before
you can do any of this so he says
however
if you do feel a suitable occasion as a
risen to do the deed be careful not to
allow its enticement and sweetness and
attractiveness to overcome you but set
over against all this the thought how
much better is the consciousness of
having won a victory over it
self-control freedom are higher values
than mere pleasure for stoics and so
this is a very practical way here in the
end caridian for a person to go about
reasoning their way practically
reasoning their way to the right
decision
when you do a thing which you have made
up your mind ought to be done never try
not to be seen doing it even though most
people are likely to think unfavorably
about it
if however what you are doing is not
right avoid the deed itself altogether
but if it is right why fear those who
are going to rebuke you wrongly
when we do things we ought to be
resolute in doing them we ought to see
them through
and not really worry about what other
people think because we don't control
what other people think so epictetus is
going to tell us when we're supposed to
be doing something
when we've got something that we've made
up our mind ought to be done we
shouldn't try to not be seen doing it
and this is often the case when we
have conflicted emotions about it or
conflicted loyalties when we we want to
live the stoic life and we want to
follow through on our duties and yet at
the same time we do actually care about
what other people think or about our
self-image or about what the
repercussions might be
when really those are externals
and they shouldn't matter they do matter
for many of us but we should try to pare
them down we have to make an effort to
push them away those sort of
considerations
so he says to us don't try to not be
seen doing it even though most people
are likely to think unfavorably about it
so you know for example if you decide
that uh you should exercise and lose
some weight and that means going to the
gym and putting on your t-shirt and your
shorts and your your you know running
shoes or whatever and going on the
machines and huffing and puffing and
being out of shape and having other
people look at you like oh what's going
on with that
fat guy that slob or something like that
don't worry about what they think that
that's not your concern your concern is
the task that you should be doing
if you've got an embarrassing family
member who you feel that you need to be
there to support you go and support them
don't worry about what other people
think about you
for coming in and hanging out with them
likewise a friend likewise a colleague
you know if you're in a business meeting
and somebody's saying something that's
untrue and you think that you need to
correct it perhaps it isn't your place
to correct it but perhaps it is then go
ahead and do it and don't worry about
you know whether somebody else is not
going to invite you to the next meeting
it's important if something really is
your duty that you do it and don't worry
about other people's viewpoints about it
now he says as well
if however what you're doing is not
right that's a different thing
then avoid the deed itself altogether if
if you think that something is wrong
and one of the reasons why we avoid
doing certain things when other people
can see us is what we think oh they're
going to see us doing something wrong
from the stoic perspective if you're
doing something wrong you're doing
something wrong it doesn't matter if
other people see you it doesn't matter
if you're all by yourself it's wrong
it's wrong
so if it's wrong just don't do it
that should be sort of a no-brainer now
it's much more difficult than that in
real life right because when we want
when we're tempted to do something wrong
there's all sorts of other reasons that
are suggesting themselves to us you know
in this this time i know it's wrong but
i'm going to make an exception here and
i'll never do it again but you know we
have to rule those those sort of things
out we have to learn how to resist those
false reasonings about it if it's wrong
don't worry about what other people
think just don't do it then he goes on
and he says if it's right why are you
going to fear those who are going to
rebuke you wrongly
if if they have a wrong-headed view
about what it is that you're doing
that's the right thing to do that's
their problem
and maybe they can sort that out maybe
you can explain it to them
but you're probably not going to get
through to them most of the time
and whether or not you get through to
them that's up to them that's their
issue that's in their control it's not
something that you need to be overly
concerned about
just as the propositions it is day and
it is night are full of meaning when
separated but meaningless if united so
also granted that for you to take the
larger share at a dinner is good for
your body still it is bad for the
maintenance of the proper kind of social
feeling
when therefore you are eating with
another person remember to regard not
merely the value for your body of what
lies before you but also to maintain
your respect for your host
i think chapter six can be a little bit
confusing for people first reading the
end caribbean because you might not see
the connection between the first part of
it this stuff about day and night and
propositions and then talking about you
know dinner and and what's what's your
share and all that so what what is the
connection between those
in a word it has to do with what we call
conflict or contradiction the the stoics
epictetus in particular are going to
talk in terms of what's in greek mache
and mache literally means battle right
it comes to mean later on any sort of
conflict so when we talk about
having internal conflicts like you don't
know how to
behave in a certain way or you've got
these mixed emotions that are kind of
jarring against each other or you're
conflicted what we often say within
yourself about how you ought to behave
that's what we're talking about
and this can happen in terms of logical
order and propositions and arrangements
and you know all that sort of stuff and
it can also happen in terms of ethical
matters and as it turns out for the
stoics these are actually interfused
with each other
because the way in which we carry out
practical reasoning that is the way in
which we reason about what what is to be
done what is to be avoided or prevented
what's good what's bad how to how to
evaluate goods and bads against each
other
all of that is not simply governed but
but sort of overlaps with logical
structure
so he starts out talking about
propositions right uh what are these
propositions it is day and it is night
right so these are these are
contraries to each other or at least
opposites you can't be day and night at
the same time and you say wait a second
what about twilight what about dawn okay
there's some limit cases there don't
worry about that so much think about
noon and midnight right noon and
midnight both are 12 but they're not the
same thing at all and so epictetus says
um
this is how it's translated just as the
propositions it is day and it is night
are full of meaning when separated from
each other
but meaningless if united
now the greek terms here
um is to say that you know instead of
saying meaningful it's eche oxian magaly
that is they have great value they have
we could say they have great meaning
great significance they mean something
real
it's day right now that i'm filming this
it actually is day that's a true
proposition
why because the sun is is out uh if i
were to do this 12 hours from now uh or
maybe 15 hours from now just make it
hedge our bets a little bit it would be
nighttime and my saying it is day would
be a clear falsehood right you like open
the blinds and you show me the dark you
say no sun out here right look there's
the stars it's nighttime buddy
so those things are meaningful when
they're they're separated from each
other
they're not as meaningful
they're actually contradictory when we
join them together into a single
compound proposition
it is day and it is night or if it is
day it is night like a hypothetical
proposition or anything anything along
these lines or it is it is day
uh
uh
because it's night well okay the this is
sort of nonsense right or or at least
it's not complete nonsense we understand
what the words mean but that that
doesn't make any any real sense you
can't say those sorts of things and have
anybody go along with it now in ethical
matters it works kind of similarly
except that it's not quite so
straightforward it's not quite so on the
surface when there is a contradiction
but a great part of what stoic ethics
consists in
is trying to work through
these contradictions trying to say if
there's a contradiction here we need to
make sense of this and you know figure
out which part we can keep usually when
there's a contradiction you can't have
both sides
and where we get into a lot of trouble
is in you know the proverbial trying to
have our cake and eat it too
that means trying to have things both
ways
usually all that that'll also mean
trying to impose something on the
universe that the universe isn't going
to go for trying to do that to some
other person
so he says
here's the other example from this
passage granted that for you to take the
larger share at a dinner is good for
your body
still it's bad for the maintenance of
the proper kind of social feeling
the the greek for this is
the you know the harmony the community
you might say the sharing
so
you can't have both of these
it is good for your body to take more
food probably i mean if you're if you're
at a dinner and there's like unlimited
food no that's not good for your body
but if you're at a typical dinner party
where people have uh you know laid out
quite a bit but the portions can can be
kind of small then yeah it would be good
for your body to do that so that's good
in one sense
right that's sort of like the day
but on the other hand if it's a goal for
you if it's a desire if it's a value
to preserve the fellow feeling the
community
that you've been brought into at the
dinner party
then that's not compatible and that's
the it is night right and you can't have
both of these at the same time
it's good for your body it's bad it's
it's good for the body it's good for the
community
these can't be reconciled in this
particular instance
now of course you know if if
they planned out the dinner a little bit
differently maybe it would be but he
says when therefore you're eating with
another person
remember this is the important point
remember direct your mind to pay
attention
not merely the value for your body of
what lies before you but also to
maintain your respect for your host or
for your fellow partakers in the dinner
your fellow diners right and we can say
this about so many other things as well
think about relationships
you want to have a good relationship
with your boyfriend girlfriend you know
partner spouse whoever it is well
there's certain things that you can't do
then and certain things that you need to
do and if you're going to maintain yes i
want to have a great relationship i want
to you know have this loving back and
forth reciprocal relationship well then
you can't monopolize the conversation
time
and maybe you like monopolizing the
conversation time if you're a big talker
right you love to talk you like to be
listened to well then
if you're going to favor this you cannot
favor this that's similar to the if you
want to favor your body you can't favor
what's good for the community what's
good for the host we can say this in
general on a much larger scale about
something that the stoics recognized as
an integral part of human nature as
animals as
animate beings
particularly as animals that can think
ahead about things
we do in fact try to do what we'll
conduce to our living well not just
surviving but
increasing our life making our life
better
sooner or later if we follow that out
exclusively that can run into
other people's trying to do the same
thing
and the stoics say that we not only have
this as a value but we also have living
in harmony with other people and being
in community being social as a value as
well
sometimes these are not compatible with
each other
for you to take the best of everything
or to try to impose your will on
everybody else that's not compatible
with
being in harmony with other human beings
having a fabric of good relationships
with them
living in a community
and so
at one point or another we may we need
to make a decision
for one of these we have to consider we
have to call to mind and say wow i've
been acting like a jerk for all this
time i need to start making this the
priority and pairing this away
maybe even making up for it or perhaps
uh you could say uh screw the community
i i'm only interested in myself you
wouldn't be a good stoic then but that's
that is a a live possibility for people
so this uh hopefully makes this this
passage much more clear to you
[Music]
you